- Hey, I'm Courtney.
- I'm Kevin.
- I'm Stephanie.
(Both laugh)
- And together.
- (laughs) And together, we
are the chicken pot pie-ers.
- Courtney is a chef, she's
also one of my best friends,
and she's written so many cookbooks,
worked in incredible famous kitchens,
and we're so lucky to have her
on the show making Elizabeth's food.
- Let's begin, shall we?
(upbeat music)
- I'm about to make the chicken pot pie
with Kevin and Stephanie,
and this is a huge, huge dish on the show.
- Yes.
- Without the chicken pot pie,
you would not have "Supper at Six".
- That's right, it's the catalyst.
Kevin's character, Walter, takes a bite
of this chicken pot pie,
and it inspires him for
the rest of this series.
- Yeah, and possibly life.
- I would like to offer you a job
as the new host of RBLA
TV's latest cooking show.
- Are you concussed?
- But you know, I know Kevin a little bit,
and he has said that
he is not a good cook,
so I'm very excited to
see how this is gonna go,
because I think he's gonna
learn a lot from you today.
- I also don't think Stephanie
is a huge cook either.
- Oh, she's not?
- So I'm really curious
to see how they do.
- Hmm, I can't wait to find out.
This is so fun!
- Me neither, me neither.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- I brought my chicken pot pie
recipe, along with a sample
so that you can taste
the crumble of the crust
and the viscosity of the filling.
- Before we get started,
please do tell me just a teensy little bit
about your characters.
- I play Fran Frask.
I am the head of HR at Hastings Lab.
Elizabeth and I bump heads a lot.
- Since the day you got
here, you have just acted
like you are so much
better than the rest of us,
marching around these halls
with your perfect little nose up
like you invented penicillin.
- I play Walter.
I am a producer at "Supper at Six".
I also bump heads with
Elizabeth quite a bit.
(laughs)
- I hear your concerns.
Thing is, TV, it needs
to be inviting and fun.
- Cooking is not fun, it is vital work.
- We're gonna start by making the filling.
So we're gonna come over here,
you're gonna dump the butter in.
- Easy.
Boom.
- Alright.
- It's already sizzling.
- Yeah, it's sizzling.
Now we're gonna add celery, carrots.
- Onions!
- So, both of you, in the
show, you have big careers.
What do you think it's like
working with your character on the show?
How do you contribute
to the work environment?
- Hmm.
- I play a TV producer, so
having been on a lot of TV sets,
we're in a room with a
bunch of different people,
and everybody brings
their own thing to it,
especially, you know, actors.
Most of them (laughs)
have something weird-
- Yeah, kind of crazy.
- About them.
- I can relate to that right now.
Deeply.
(laughs)
- With Fran, she's head of HR.
She follows the rules, she
gets everybody excited to do-
Ooh, we're adding in the
chicken, the shredded chicken.
- But keep talking, you're doing great.
- I mean, I can relate to her,
because I think she tries to add a lot
of fun to the workplace,
but she's a bit of a strict rule follower.
- Yeah.
- Which can be
probably obnoxious.
- Are you a rule follower in real life?
- To some.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Really, you're kind of like Fran?
Do you relate to Fran?
- More than I'd like to admit, yeah.
- There is protocol, Miss Zott.
When you don't follow
protocol, it falls on me.
(mellow music)
- You're just gonna do this,
and the goal is you want
it to be pretty thin,
about like this.
I'm gonna place this here for now.
Do you see the butter in here?
- Oh, that's butter.
- So this is butter.
That's what makes it really
flaky and crispy and delicious.
Alright, you're doing great.
- Lots of.
- Yeah.
- Oh, it's, okay.
- Get the elbow grease.
- So I’m not gonna have to do arms.
- Yeah, you're just doing--
- Is it normal
to throw out your back doing this?
- Sometimes, yeah.
- Uh-oh, wait, is that?
- Alright, I'm gonna take this.
- That is, like, so thin, brother.
- I know.
- Yeah, did I make it too thin?
- No, I mean, well, maybe, but it's okay.
It's gonna work.
It's still gonna work great.
(sighs)
- I think that if I were gonna
make a dish for somebody,
for like my husband, it
would be probably just
like angel hair and basil.
- What kind of noodle?
Angel hair?
- Yeah.
- I love that.
- Or capellini.
- I like fusilli.
- Fusilli?
- Yeah.
- What's the difference there?
- That's the--
- The spirals?
- Isn't that fusilli?
- Yeah, I think the
point of the spirals is
that the little bits of meat
go in the little grooves
of the spiral.
- Ooh, yeah.
- Yeah, I love fusilli, what can I say?
- Did you see how well that I rolled this?
- I know, it--
- I am a rule follower.
- Yes.
- Like I said.
- We have our dough, we have our filling,
so we're each gonna assemble one.
I'm just gonna cut a
square about this size
to put in the bottom,
then I'm gonna cut round
like this for the top.
Then you just put the
pie dough in the cup,
push it into the bottom,
make sure it goes all
the way to the edges.
Trim it so there's just about,
I don't know, what is that?
Half an inch of an overhang
all around the edge.
Just like that.
So do y'all wanna do that?
- Okay, we got the circle.
- Circle.
- Now we got the square.
We're gonna place the square on top.
- Yeah.
- There's nothing better
than the feeling of cutting dough.
- Mm-hmm, I agree.
- Is that weird?
- No.
- Would pie dough be the
same for like an actual pie,
or would that be, like a dessert pie?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so this
pie dough is very versatile.
You can use it for savory,
you could use it for dessert.
- Can I eat it?
- Yeah.
It's literally just flour and butter, so.
- It's really good.
- Yeah.
- Oh, boy, I didn't think I
was gonna make it through that.
- It looks great.
- You did it.
- Thank you.
- Okay, so now we're
just gonna fill these.
Literally just get your spoon in there
and fill it to the top.
- Okay.
(mellow jazzy music)
- Now, put the top on,
and then you're just gonna fold it over-
- Cute, yes.
- The top like this.
So you really wanna pinch it to seal it,
and then even if it doesn't
seal all the way right now,
we are gonna egg wash them.
Literally you just
brush the tops with egg.
It is exactly what it sounds like.
And then you wanna vent the pie
so that the steam can escape.
- Alright, I'm gonna do.
Cool.
- Here you go.
- Okay.
- Gorgeous.
- And then we'll put these in the oven,
and let these bake, and
we'll give 'em a taste.
- The starch goes through a
process called retrogradation
where the molecules restructure
into a crystalline form.
The flavor compounds are
trapped in said structure,
which makes every bite more flavorful.
- Yeah, I definitely
tasted the extra molecules.
- What do you think makes
the best first date?
Dinner at home, picnic, or a restaurant?
- My fiance and I, our
first date was a picnic.
- Really?
- Aw.
- That's a really good first date.
- Mm-hmm.
- What about you?
- I would say restaurant,
and I was thinking with my husband.
That's a good first date.
- Was that y'all's first
date, at a restaurant?
- Yeah, and it's just so
romantic if you go to a good one.
- Yeah, true.
- It's nice.
- Yeah.
- Treat yourself.
- Can I take you to dinner tonight?
- Yes, yes, I would very much like that.
- So be careful, 'cause-
- Wow.
- This is hot.
- It's like oozing out.
- This is like the filling and the butter,
just like, a soupy, soupy filling.
Alright, spoon.
- Yeah.
- Spoon.
- Is it gonna be too hot?
- Let's see.
Ready?
- The color is perfect.
- It's so perfect.
You really know how to do this.
- Oh my gosh.
Mm-hmm.
- Oh my gosh, mm!
Going in for another bite.
Oh my gosh, this is so good.
We've gotta get the crispy pastry.
- Mm-hmm.
- And there's a chewiness.
- Yeah, you know what I love?
- It's the combo.
You break through the crispiness,
and then plunge into a
chewiness, more of a gooeyness.
- And they all taste like this?
Like, chicken pot pies,
are they all this texture,
or is this a special way to make it?
- This is a special one.
Thank you so much for coming today.
I had so much fun.
It was great.
- Thanks for teaching us.
- Yeah.
- Yes,
this was a delicious lesson.
- Yay.
And you can learn more
about these characters
and the food in "Lessons
in Chemistry" on AppleTV+.
- Yay.
(mellow music)